[Music]
we remember being in third grade this is
how we talked this is how we acted and
you know I think most people if they
really think hard you know if everyone
everyone talks about oh the beauty and
naivety of children and but if you think
back to what you were in third grade you
were just everyone was kind of a rotting
jerk that's what's so fun fun about it
for us is that it's it's so real that
it's that the title of the premiere
episode is harboring getting the navel
probe that didn't happen to us in third
grade that's an embellishment just
somewhat under development
was it the ones that the big long heads
and the black eyes yeah I think that
they and us together Comedy Central on
us together made a conscious effort to
be like okay let's not just focus on
just foul language for the sake of foul
language and that was really the thing
we we focused on was yes let the kids
talk the way they talk and if they just
have to say something like that then
they should but but it shouldn't be the
point of the show but I think staying
away from like just the gratuitous kind
of like let's let's see his curse words
just for the sake of it I think it's
made to show a lot better do you not to
rely on that you're gonna rely more
sophisticated humor in my car jokes yeah
[Music]
we had heard Oh George clean is a big
fan and reliable that's cool because we
had hurt a lot of people a big fans but
George was like cool enough just like
really embrace us you know and it wasn't
just it wasn't just lip service he was
like let me do a voice yeah actually we
were with George at that he invite us to
the Batman premiere party and so we're
just standing around Jorah and of course
you know people are just swimming yes
that Georgia say you're partying George
is like hey I want you guys to meet
these guys
[Music]